par mi temps
[Musique]
bonjour
vous avez vu cette vieille poussette
elle est drôle n'est ce pas
et puis regardez ce qu'il y a deux dans
une quantité de vieilles choses
amusantes
tout ceci vient du grenier de mon oncle
archibald
il y en avait tellement que l'on pouvait
à peine rentré alors j'ai profité du
fait qu'il soit parti en vacances pour
tout débarrasser il va être vraiment
autant rentrer il pourra dire qu'il a un
neveu vraiment gentil et j'ai eu une
idée extraordinaire pour débarrasser
tout ça très vite j'avais mis la
poussette juste sous la fenêtre
ensuite je suis remonté au grenier et
j'ai tout jeté par la fenêtre mal
malheureusement tout est tombé à côté
alors il a fallu que je ramasse tout
enfin bon je dois aller jeter toutes ces
vieilles choses à la décharge municipale
elle est à 5 km et ça monte
enfin heureusement ça ça descendra au
retour enfin malheureusement à ce moment
là dans la poussette sera vide
qu'est ce que j'en pense
bon ça ne te pleurent le garde champêtre
ya pas de la population pour lui faire
une communication importante
bon il faut que j'aille écouter ça je
reviendrai après
bon cet endroit monsieur martin roth
s'est pas l'endroit qui fait le pêcheur
c'est la manière qui compte mais si vous
trempez votre ligne dans un pays noir ou
un arabe au on attrape à jamais que des
gangs 3net des réponses enfin bien
entendu mais à partir du moment où il ya
du poisson il faut encore savoir la
troupe et
je vous parie et six poissons que vous
avez péché que j'attrape au moins du
poisson en moins de dix secondes en
moins de 10 secondes il vous pariez quoi
lavaud rooney
6 modes de radis 120 temps plein qui
s'est conclu tu aimerais être très très
attentif
voilà
parti à
moi et moi j'ai attrapé le poisson j'ai
réussi
j'ai attrapé un poisson allez je suis
bon joueur monsieur martin je vous donne
le lien vous pourrez toujours le faire
mariner à l'inpi bientôt pâques on va se
régaler vous n'êtes europe où les que
des idées
je vous épargne et d'attraper un poisson
je ne vous ai pas parlé de le sortir de
l'eau pauvre pêcheur
un mot
[Musique]
mais factor vous n'êtes plus facteurs à
6 casimir je suis toujours facteur c'est
un métier auquel je tiens tron pour le
quitter alors mais si j'ai changé ma
casquette de facteurs contre celle de
garde champêtre c'est que celui ci me
l'a demandé et oui parce qu'aujourd'hui
il est au mariage de sa fille cadette
alors il m'a demandé de le remplacer
voilà bien j'ai une proclamation aligne
très bien et bien vous écoutons un
factor us je vais vous dire la tempête
[Musique]
alice avis à la population
la décharge municipale de lille aux
enfants est suffisamment grande mais
n'est pas immense or il a été remarqué
que certains habitants jeté aux ordures
des choses qui sont encore en bon état
et qu'ils peuvent encore servir en
conséquence afin de ne pas risquer de
faire déborder la dite des charges la
municipalité demande aux habitants de
bien vouloir ne pas y jeter des objets
encore en état
qu'on se le dise
vous avez été très bien merci bien et
casimir mais
j'ai mal choisi un bon moment parce que
c'est l'heure de la sieste et y'a pas
grand monde je m'aligne placardé cet
avis ah ah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
voilà et bien maintenant il ne me
restait plus qu'à aller coiffer ma chère
casquette de facteurs avec un peu
d'émotion je repose a fait
quasiment tourné
au mais j'y pense je vais faire une
bêtise énorme en voulant jeter dans la
décharge tout tous ces vieux objets
finalement je crois qu'il y a il ya des
tas de choses qui peuvent encore servir
qu'est ce que je pourrais bien en fait
les vendre ah mais vous me donnez une
idée formidable les enfants merci merci
qu'ils auraient à y penser tant qu'il
a je suis content je m'ennuyais de ces
temps derniers mais cuisine vient de me
trouver une occupation qui
m'enthousiasme il m'a demandé de tenir
le magasin d'antiquités qu'il vient de
créer ici je dois apprendre ou échanger
tous les vieux objets provenant du
grenier l'ancrage margival tout le monde
est au courant je ne devrais pas tarder
à voir déclinons
moi quelqu'un
salutations aux affaires léonard
je viens avec un ami voir s'il ya
quelque chose je veux faire mon bonheur
dans tout ce bric à brac en mai à
lisieux du snob jeter un coup d'oeil sur
la vous engage à rien
oh que vois-je des costes non c'est
aussi beaux les uns que les autres
mais s'il vous plaît nous pourrons
sûrement j'ai à faire je pense bien qui
me plaisent mais dis-moi léonard si j'ai
bien compris ce que m'a dit casimir on
peut non seulement acheter mais aussi
échanger exactement monsieur du snob si
l'originalité d'une autre et chant oui
et bien je choisis les choses
[Musique]
ici votre droit monsieur du snos est
votre endroit dos alors je prends
ces costumes là comme dans niveau en
échange ale justement j'ai dans ma
valise des costumes que je ne porte plus
voilà regarde si ça peut faire la faire
on pense qu
on me cite un échange équitable
ils sont plus beaux
et plus prendre bon eh bien très bien
oui parfois je savais trop mis trop vu
n'est ce pas voilà alors j'ai pris les
costumes et je te laisse et les miens
ben oui c'est les rues d'un seul coup je
change tout ma garde-robe et voilà nos
principes a ainsi que le client soit
content bon vais très bien à le re non
bon revoir mon bon merci beaucoup
les affaires sont bonnes
pas une et anar
bonjour julie a dû en
témoignent les deux mon général
voyons as-tu des affaires susceptibles
de m'intéresser
sans aucun doute il y en a pour tous les
goûts
formidable justement ce que cherchait
des beaucoup pour mes bonbons
je peux te les échanges et amélie mais
bien sûr comme un pont construit et bien
justement des bocaux aussi qui viennent
de mon coeur qui sont très propres mais
j'ai envie de changer cela je les
trouverai jeunes arbres j'aime bien les
affaires rondement mené temps plein
bonjour mes amis je vais vous raconter
aujourd'hui une fable de jean de la
fontaine le corbeau et le renard
alphonse et césar ici présents joueront
des rôles de ces deux célèbres
personnages
et moi désolé il n'y a que deux rouges
maître corbeau de chalon sur un arbre
perché tenait en son bec un fromage
maître renard par l'odeur alléché
vitasse à peu près ce langage qu'est ce
qu'il sent mauvais ce fromage
alphonse en est pas à trop parler en bas
je sais mais il sent mauvais mais
c'était toi ou cp ranger qui comptent
appeler
maintenant
maître renard par l'odeur alléché 8 un
peu frais sont longues et bonjour
monsieur du corbeau que vous êtes jolie
que vous me semblez bourgeois bref
encore une réflexion comme celle là et
je te transforme en poplar sans mentir
si votre ramage se rapporte à votre
image dépêche toi ô vous êtes les phénix
des hôtes de ces bois
à ces mots là corbeau ne se sent plus de
soi et pour montrer sa belle voix il
ouvre à large bec et laisse tomber sa
femme
valeur 100 kg teddy
il complètement écrasé le renard centre
est dit est dit je n'y arrive pas ce
n'est pas le texte oh là là mon bon
monsieur apprenez que tout flatteur vit
au dépend de celui qui l'écouté cette
leçon vaut bien un fromage sans doute un
hammam à la
ceni c'est dégoûtant le corbeau honteux
et confus jura mais un peu tard qu'on ne
l'y prendrait plus vraiment non plus on
ira prendra plus
[Musique]
[Rires]
alors casimir tu es satisfait de l'ena a
enchanté il a pratiquement tout est
changé et il le plus drôle c'est que
nous nous retrouvons pratiquement avec
les mêmes objets mais plus une offre est
la poussière en moins je dois dire que
question échange je me débrouille pas
mal du tout c'est vrai
alors on clarifie balle oui vous êtes
déjà rentrés de vacances ça s'est bien
passé oui vous avez vu la lettre laissée
par casimir oui
oui
ne quittez pas une seconde oncle
archibald casimir donc l'archipel
n'apprécie pas du tout le nettoyage fait
par le vide dans son grenier on trouve
qu'à un grenier vide sans vieillir et
poussiéreuses c'est aussi triste qu'un
jardin sont fleurs lors il te demande de
tout rapporter dans les plus brefs
délais bon là quelle catastrophe tu as
entendu oncle archibald et bien casimir
est d'accord et oui il va toujours
apporté en voyant que l'archivage
non mais en france on qu'est ce que tu
as accompli c'est bien quand je ne peux
pas puisque je ne les ai plus ces objets
dans casimir venir il ya peut-être une
solution avons alors de la moi vite un
île et casimir tu va rapporter à l'oncle
archibal tous que les honneurs obtenu
grâce à ces échanges les civic
rapprochement allofs l'archipel ce qui
s'est passé puisqu'il retrouvera à peu
près les mêmes vieilleries
dans le mail horde et bien il te
pardonnera certainement bon franchement
bravo bravo j'ai saisi casimir tué son
véhicule et non non non il ya une chose
à laquelle françois n'a pas pensé
et bien tous ces objets étaient
recouverts de poussière et de poindre
d'araignée
est alors
née alors dit alors tu vas prendre ce
ballet faire le ménage à fond dans ma
maison nous formons un gros tas de
poussière et de toiles d'araignées elle
nous laisse ou poseront sur les mon
casimir